à berlin devant le bundestag jacques
chirac a donc donné sa vision de
l'europe
à trois jours de la présidence française
de l'union européenne et a choisi la
coupole de verre du reichstag tout un
symbole pour s'engager en faveur d'une
constitution européenne et la création
avec l'allemagne d'un groupe pionnier
d'état qui souhaiteraient aller plus
loin et plus vite dans la construction
de l'europe sur place véronique saint
olive et jean paul chaussée berlin ville
chantier symbole de l'allemagne
réunifiée désormais carrefour de
l'europe et c'est là au bundestag que le
président de la république a voulu
relancer la construction européenne un
discours solennel qui engage la france
mais qui permet surtout à jacques chirac
sans lionel jospin à ses côtés de donner
sa propre vision d'une europe bientôt
élargie à 30 membres accéléré pour
éviter l'enlisement
le président de la république propose
qu'un groupe de pays pionniers réunis
autour de la france et de l'allemagne
ouvre la voie et pour la première fois
jacques chirac s'engagent en faveur
d'une constitution européenne qui
permettrait de savoir qui fait quoi
nous pourrions également réfléchir dans
le cadre de ce processus aux frontières
géographiques ultime de l'union préciser
la nature de la charte des droits
fondamentaux
préparez les ajustements institutionnels
nécessaires
les gouvernements puis les peuples
seraient appelés à se prononcer sur un
texte que nous pourrons alors consacré
comme la première constitution
européenne
mais prudent jacques chirac rassure
aussi les eurosceptiques s'est déformé
la vérité de dire qu'il ya d'un côté
ceux qui défendent la souveraineté
nationale et de l'autre ceux qui la
brade ni vous ni nous envisageons la
création d'un super état européen
qui se substituerait à nos états nations
avec ce discours jacques chirac veut se
poser comme le leader d'une europe
élargie et renforcée comme celui qui
crée la dynamique comme celui qui à deux
ans des présidentielles prépare les
évolutions de la france une façon pour
lui de reprendre la main désormais
carrefour de l'europe que le président
de la république a voulu relancer la
construction européenne un discours
solennel qui engage la france mais qui
permet surtout à jacques sirat sans
lionel jospin à ses côtés de donner sa
propre vision d'une europe bientôt
élargie à 30 membres accéléré pour
éviter l'enlisement
le président la république propose qu'un
groupe de pays pionniers réunis autour
de la france et de l'allemagne ouvre la
voie et pour la première fois jacques
chirac s'engagent en faveur d'une
constitution européenne qui permettrait
de savoir qui fait quoi
nous pourrions également réfléchir dans
le cadre de ce processus aux frontières
géographiques ultime de l'union préciser
la nature de la charte des droits
fondamentaux
préparez les ajustements institutionnels
nécessaires
les gouvernements puis les peuples
seraient appelés à se prononcer sur un
texte que nous pourrons alors consacré
comme la première constitution
européenne les président jacques chirac
rassure aussi les eurosceptiques s'est
déformé la vérité de dire qu'il ya d'un
côté ceux qui défendent la souveraineté
nationale et de l'autre ceux qui la
brade ni vous ni nous envisageons la
création d'un super état européen qui se
substituerait à nos états nations avec
ce discours jacques chirac veut se poser
comme le leader d'une europe élargie et
renforcée comme celui qui crée la
dynamique comme celui qui à deux ans des
présidentielles prépare les évolutions
de la france
une façon pour lui de reprendre la main